Guys, have you ever looked at
your hands, and you're like,
why do I have these?
Hey, peeps, this is D News.
Thanks for watching.
Sometimes when
you're sitting around
in your friend's basement
and you're all zoned out,
and you look down at your heavy
limbs and you start pondering,
why do we have
four of these, man?
Bats got four, and monkeys and
lizards and frogs and birds
and drag-- you get the idea.
I'm not saying
that's what happened.
But a team of scientists
from the University of Vienna
wanted to know exactly why
limbs always come in pairs,
and published their
model in the journal
Evolution and Development.
By the way, it has to
deal with our tummy.
I like to point out that
this is the hypothesis.
The researchers have
created a model.
And now that it's
published, other researchers
can begin to study it.
They will pick it
apart for accuracy
and tweak it over time.
This is science in action.
Of all the known
species on the planet,
both living and extinct, those
with both a backbone and a jaw
all have paired appendages .
Using information from molecular
embryology, paleontology,
and classical morphology,
the researchers
examined all these
jawed vertebrates
known as gnathostomes in
as basic a state as we can,
by looking at their
gene expression
and embryonic development.
Their model explains
the reason we
have paired appendages
is because of the three
types of basic tissues
in a developing embryo.
The ectoderm becomes the
skin and nervous system,
the mesoderm, which forms
muscles, bones, and organs,
and the endoderm, which
forms the digestive tract.
Usually the mesoderm
splits into two layers
to line the body
cavity and the gut.
And if those layers are
sufficiently separated,
they'll form into limbs
right below the gut.
Why?
Because the developing gut
keeps the layers nearby
too close together to
form those appendages.
As the body forms, the
end of the digestive tract
fits between the legs,
and everything else
just kind of closes
up down there.
Above the gut, the mesoderm and
ectoderm are messing around.
And they form
another set of limbs
with the separated tissue.
Two sets of opposing
appendage pairs, all
because that digestive
tissue sits in the middle.
Thanks, belly.
If this works out, we'll
have a great theory
on why all the gnathostomes
have two pairs of limbs.
We'll have to wait and see
if the science pans out.
Would you rather have more arms?
Maybe another set, like
down here or something?
Where?
How?
Grab your keyboards and
head down to the comments
to share your
[INAUDIBLE] dreams.
Thanks a lot for watching
D News, everybody.